hey youtubers is Charlie so this video
is going to be all about Lady Stoneheart
who she is what's going on in the books
and how the show might be changing that
so just careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened so far and I
will be talking about Lady Stoneheart
stuff from the books if you haven't read
the books the reason why everyone's
going so crazy about Lady Stoneheart
maybe coming on the show is because of a
very specific actor that the show
included in last week's episode named
LEM Lemon cloak who's part of Lady
Stoneheart spanned the Brotherhood
without banners when people asked him if
that's who he was playing he pretty much
said yeah and then they followed up by
saying isn't it weird that you didn't
hang everyone and he replied yeah it's
almost like we're teasing something not
saying we are but wink wink and a lot of
people were just like oh my god he's
teasing Lady Stoneheart but because
we're following up with the Hound
anything Lady Stoneheart related is
going to be a little bit different from
the books we don't even really meet her
til towards the end of book 4 so I'm
gonna go ahead and have to you know
introduce who Lady Stoneheart is so
spoiler warning here we go
Lady Stoneheart is the resurrected
Catelyn Stark on a revenge tear just
killing any phrase anyone associated
with the phrase anyone associated with
the red wedding anyone who's ever talked
to a Frey gets hung from a tree so the
way she's introduced in the books is
three days after the red wedding so
remember charting the timeline here were
way past the red wedding on the TV show
Nymeria areas dire wolf pulls Catelyn
Stark's corpse out of the river here as
people approach she runs off so that's
the last we see of Nymeria for a little
while but the corpse of Catelyn Stark is
sitting there the Brotherhood without
banners and beric Dondarrion who are in
the Riverlands find her barrack gives
her what he calls the last kiss where he
basically transfers his life force that
has been given to him by the Red Guard
or returned to him by the red God
remember he's been resurrected six times
so he gives his life force to Catelyn
Stark dying in the process she is
resurrected but she's like this
desiccated corpse so she's like this
haunted risen zombie which I'll explain
in just a second but basically she takes
over the Brotherhood without banners
because she's Catelyn Stark everyone
swears fealty to her and she just starts
eviscerating anyone associated with the
red wedding so we have learned a little
bit about Resurrection via the red God
through Thor's of mirror and now more
silly with Jon Snow's resurrection but
as is explained in the books the longer
you're gone the less of you there is to
return so very little of Catelyn Stark
returns well she can remember his
revenge so any sweetness that was in her
is completely gone now she's really like
the ghostwriter version of Catelyn Stark
so she's just fantastic just his
absolute total badass but then later in
book 4 Brienne is looking for Sansa
throughout the Riverlands and runs into
the Brotherhood without banners they
take her back to Lady Stoneheart when
Lady Stoneheart sees her Bri and swears
fealty to her Lady Stoneheart says you
must kill Jaime Lannister brands like no
he's changed Jaime isn't the same person
I can't kill him
she promptly gets hung from a tree as
she's dying she shouts out a word we
don't find out what that word is but
George R Martin later confirmed it to be
sword as in the choice to take Jaime by
sword or be hung from the tree so it's
like Brienne saying okay fine I'll go
kill Jaime so getting back to the show
the producer said that she wasn't part
of the conversation for season 4 which
is logically where she would have
appeared and now even though there's
been teasers like this limb Lemon cloak
stuff in that the Hound storyline with
him going to get the Brotherhood without
banners it still seems like the show is
conspiring to cut her out that doesn't
mean that they did cut her out she could
totally appear but it seems like she's
not george RR martin has even said
recently that the show has cut her out
so just be prepared for Lady Stoneheart
to completely be cut out of the show
what her storyline is all about is being
the avatar of revenge for the stark
family and I think they've largely given
that to the Sansa character like she's
seeking revenge for her family and then
even though you have Brienne in the
Riverlands near Riverrun so she's in
Lady Stoneheart serie so a lot of people
like wolf brands down here maybe we'll
still see Lady Stoneheart
but it seems like in the books Lady
Stoneheart wanted her to go after Jaime
and they've teased this conflict between
Brienne and Jaime on the show so it
seems like they just completely jumped
over Lady Stoneheart so you guys can let
me know in the comments even though the
actor the LEM Lemon cloak actor teased
possible Lady Stoneheart do you think
that George R Mardan is telling the
truth and the show has completely
skipped her over some of you have asked
if I think that Arya will become Lady
Stoneheart
assume your you're talking about just
seeking revenge and killing a bunch of
phrase like killing Walder Frey I do
think we'll see that revenge but I'm not
really going to call it Lady Stoneheart
esque because you'd have to die be
resurrected as this desiccated corpse so
there's not really one person you could
point to and call Lady Stoneheart you
could say Sansa is getting part of her
story at least the matically but she's
way up in the north doing completely
different things so the show is just
like completely jumped over that
storyline which I know is kind of a
bummer but I still think there'll be
some big WTF one of the good things
about the show is when they do cut
things out sometimes they'll show us
scenes that wouldn't necessarily appear
in the books Martin also implied that
you know because we got the big Hodor
reveal a couple of episodes ago that
even though that is why Hodor is called
Hodor the way that reveal plays out of
the books is going to be very different
so it's almost going to feel like a
completely different story even though
we reach some of the same conclusions so
in that same vein a lot of people were
like maybe Syrio Forel is coming back in
arias storyline because there are so
many theories about what's going on with
re oh yeah The Fight Club theory you
have the jaqen H'ghar theory now there's
the Syrio Forel theory and even Melo's
the actor who plays Syrio Forel was
winking at people on twitter so they
were just like oh my god this is amazing
Syrio Forel is coming back but I think
in some of these cases like the lemon
lemon cloak case it's the actors just
having a little bit of fun because HBO
would probably sue their pants off if
they spoiled the plot that's such a big
thing for them they've been very
litigious this season about people that
have been spoiling aspects of the show
so I don't think any of the recent
Twitter teasers are actual spoilers I
think it's just the actors having fun
but what I do think is going to happen
is we'll just see some Easter eggs that
they probably tried to wink at Lady
Stoneheart with some of the scenes some
of the things that they did like hanging
in McShane killing him in a way that
Lady Stoneheart would have killed him
that's like her signature takedown
hanging you from a tree so I definitely
think that we'll eventually see some
hardcore revenge for the red wedding
Lady Stoneheart style even if Lady
Stoneheart
isn't a part of that but giveaway time
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video just a $20 Amazon gift card just
like normal there will be at least one
more bonus video on Sunday before I post
my episode 8 video so
all kinds awesome game of Thrones stuff
happening we'll have to talk about winds
of winter soon but that's going to be
the finale so that's not going to be for
a couple more weeks while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for my episode 7 video and you can
click here for my breakdown of all of
brans visions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight